so I'm Katy poor famine data scientist
and so you can see what's being viewed
right now and that's live EEG data and
that's coming from my lovely assistant
that has accepted to wear the muse
headband
now this presentation is going to not be
so much focused on the neuro but how do
you take a dataset something like this
but you may not necessarily know about
and build a prototype about that what
are the steps that are required to go
through that so this is going to be
focused on my personal project and
that's called brain drain where I'm
using brain waves and machine learning
techniques to detect errors and human
problem solving so this actually goes
back to when I first started my
undergrad when I went to school I decide
I'm going to be a psych major I took
some courses in my high school and I was
like yeah this is awesome and I took one
class in college and realized this is
not for me
so some major changes later I discovered
my love of computer science but the idea
cut the brain and how it works
stuck with me all those years and that's
kind of where when it came to do my
senior research project which is a
requirement at my university to do
before you graduate I wanted to do
something with the brain but in
particular something with student
learning I've been a TA and tutor and my
mom's also an education and educator and
so I've always been a part of the
classroom and so I want to do something
with that and big data but wasn't
exactly really sure what should I do and
then I started thinking I want to like
hackathons and I remember seeing these
EEG devices that where people were using
and we realize there's a lot more
medical products that becoming open to
the public
normally that you would only see in a
doctor's office or a hospital will the
consumer the average consumer can use
these products now so there's an
opportunity to really start developing
in this field and that's where I
determine my goal I wanted to develop a
model now correlate brain activity with
problem-solving performance and then use
this model to in turn predict
performance from brain activity that's a
lot big words or exactly does that mean
let's say someone's sitting there and
they're trying to figure out an outcome
start struggling well a little
notification pops up
says hey you might actually be going
about this the wrong way so it says in
between the user and the notification of
hey you might be thinking about this
incorrectly try going back and it's a
circle until they successfully solves a
problem so this is granel I have a goal
but I want to use brain waves and all
these crazy things I'm not a neurologist
I barely take in and haven't really even
taken a neuro class so I had to do some
basic background I just want to go ahead
and say most of the research I've done
is been thanks to Google Scholar so just
beware it and don't take the as a
hundred percent true so but there are
four main brain types the alpha beta so
beta and Delta I decided want to focus
mostly on the beta and that's because
the for your active concentration is
this is where your problem-solving is
occurring and it's really only dominant
during those stages otherwise it's your
alpha and your resting and theta when
you're starting to daydream and Delta is
the most dominant in your deep sleep so
how is I going to collect this though so
I decide on the views headband which was
release in summer 2012 and it's
currently marketed as a meditation
assistant application what is that
so basically you sit there and you first
off think about dogs or cats and sports
crazy things about that and I calibrate
the device from here you start thinking
about your breathing and if you stop
thinking about it and start thinking
about other things instead of hearing
nice cool ocean breezes a storm starts
rolling in and so the news haven't
already had that feedback capability
which is what I wanted you guys headband
which you can see on Angelo it has
sensors in the front and they go around
the side to the back of your ear and it
also does jaw detection and I blink
detection so it has a lot of
capabilities and it also gives me the
four main brain types I guess what's
something what the muse has been called
raw SSP values now if you never use fast
Fourier transform before to give it as
it takes a signal which is often in the
space of its time or just space in
general and it converts the signal into
frequency domain and the mute ASIS and
automatically calculates a Hamming
window of 256 samples that are slid over
by 22 samples which is about 10 to the
second give you a 90% over life so all
of this together with the raw FFT values
that means calls it's supposed to help
reduce noise and try to get rid of any
of that random static that's a signal
might pick up so this great I have a
basic background on neuro thanks to
Google Scholar but is there any other
research has been similar to mine and
that's kind of the next step you should
take and that's where I discovered
classification of patterns of EEG
synchronization for seizure patients
another study really stood out to me
because they wanted to focus on testing
different classifiers so they took by
various features and one dose of 5
seconds basically saying this user is
having a seizure they're not having a
seizure
pretty straightforward now they
concluded that the best combination with
brainwave prediction was a convolutional
neural network with a wavelet transform
since they're using FFT they said use
wavelet so I hadn't listened my research
setup but kind of time now I need to do
my actual methodology where am I going
how am I going to build this model where
am I going to get my data from so I
decided I Ramon etre student brain
patterns using the metes headband and
trained on brainwave values to create
the model then I would develop an
application to provide direct feedback
so gathering my data required doing
experiments so during my first
experiment runs do I want to do
something simple I don't worked with an
ETL yet for this and wasn't really sure
how or what was the best way to set it
up so because of the Meuse lab which you
guys saw earlier it's a job application
created for your muse developers and
what's really nice about it is that it
automatically convert
the signals into CSV so it's easy to
work with so dudes make sure the
timestamps synced up as closely as
possible I had to write this as a job
application for my experiment and in
this java application i was able to
record whenever the question was shown
and when it was answered and also forgot
it correct or incorrect and exactly what
the problem was so that left me with two
CSV files on one side I had my answer
which was the time show and I'm
answering if they got it correct but
then I had the muse file which was this
very long long file of just completely
different things such as is the elements
is good low frequency absolute loss if I
didn't need I needed to merge this and
just pull out the information I wanted
so I wanted to visualize this I didn't
know exactly what's in this data or
what's going on with it so our studio is
kind of my go-to what I want to do
visualizations and especially because
ggplot is so strong so we're actually
going to head to our studio now and I
have these two data files already loaded
so here's my data AG now it might look a
little different so I went ahead and
just aggregated and took the mean of all
those signals and you might see a lot of
times as for one is for each of the
signal somebody needs headband so I just
took the me and then I have my other
file the answer so why they got correct
or incorrect and I went ahead already
and just added an indexed ID so nothing
too fancy but now I want to start
appending them I'm going to go ahead and
use I'll apply
and can you guys see that okay sell
small oh okay I don't think I can make
it bigger um anyways so I take I want to
say take data argh and add this new
column it's going to be called question
and L apply so for every row take the
data art time and pass into this
function and this function is going to
take a subset of my answer where it says
find where the time occur between time
shown and time answered and my answer
folder and you might be a little curious
why am i dividing it by a thousand well
if you go into the data art you can see
it's pretty much a whole number
well Java did something a little
interesting and it made it into a
decimal for my other file so it may have
been the same date time but if just put
in a different format so dividing by a
thousand helps correct for that so I'm
going to go ahead and run this sometimes
it takes longer than others
all right and then you have to unlist
everything so now I am left with a data
set that should have a question on it
but you might be a little curious wiser
na everywhere from just ahead
well I start recording on the muse
headband prior to when the questions are
prom so I have data that doesn't even
have a question associated with it so
just for a validation check I'm going to
go ahead and view it and if I scroll
down here oh there you go you can see
that the questions line up now not right
now due to time usually though you would
go through and look at a couple lines
and make sure that it did sync correctly
that's great but I need to still merge
them but since we have this question IV
now
and all my answer has that ID row we're
going to we converge on that so it's
going to call my nice merge function so
I say merge this DF which is my x value
an answer which is my Y and that's why
you say C by X so it's saying look at
this one and it's going to be with
questioning column and then in the Y
which is answer look for ID and go ahead
and merge on that so we'll take the head
of merged and you can see it's all
combined and now we can actually do a GD
plot so you can see over here this is
kind of what we want to make I want to
see the incorrect versus correct and the
four main different the types of brain
waves so I can go ahead so do you plot
it up so I want to take a subset and
you'll see that here so I'll take a
subset of merge and I say when type is
equal to one of these values then go
ahead and plot it otherwise ignore it
and you can see in my GM smooth I'm
saying X is equal to the negative and
that's because if you look closely here
I want to see what it looks like when
all what the EEG data look like a point
everything was done what was the last
thoughts did they think they were
corrected I think incorrect but there's
something different about it so I run
that and I'm left with something very
similar but if you notice the columns
aren't exactly right and this actually
gave me some trouble originally until I
figured out that you can pass in a
function to a wave graph labeler I think
this is a really powerful tool when you
want to start doing all these different
facet graphs to show a lot of data at
once so I went ahead and created this
little function so I passing the value
right and I'm saying if the value is
equal to type so if it's from this
column right so when it goes to label
each one of these say it's alpha beta
theta and Delta and then otherwise if
it's equal to correct so referencing
this column it's going to be now called
incorrect and correct so I say that as a
function and I can recall my GG plot and
if you look right here I call labeler
and then I get a call my function and I
went ahead and add some GG titles
already for it but let's see so now we
actually have a graph that shows a lot
of that data and what's the difference
between incorrect and correct thinking
so now it's kind of let's go back and
analyze it a bit so immediately what do
you see what's different between the two
so the incorrect is obviously longer has
I have a lot more data that's over a
longer period of time and correct
thinking was so short it's and there's
some questions that definitely maybe
they bumped it it got moved sensor got
messed up something happened there so
it's this is the greatest graph to
really say I should build a model off of
these experiments so have to go back and
relook at everything and it's obviously
that and the reasons that it was short
was because of the test subjects emember
tricks so if you remember something
of an even number you automatically know
it's to this slide to and not prime and
also if you see a larger number people
are going to get scared I know I
wouldn't want to sit there and think
about is this a prime number so they'll
just randomly guess and they could get
lucky but it also skews my data and also
the probability that the number is prime
so prime numbers follow that one over Ln
X shape so it's if the number is bigger
it's probably not going to be prime so
it's just not a good example experiment
for me to use so it is something that a
lot of people hate me for I'm taking
college students through three-digit
division and three digit multiplication
problems by hand so turns out a lot of
kids by college don't remember how to do
those problems so logical hated me
afterward instead of it and this Camaro
is set up the same way it was I know
when the problem was shown I knew when
the problem was finished every user was
able every test subject was able to have
a piece of paper and a pencil
they had unlimited time and the majority
of the test users were veil between the
ages of 18 and 25 and this is from
gathered from students that attended
hackathons in the state of Florida
so I tried to get a wide variety of just
not students at my school now most of
these students obviously we're computer
science so maybe a little skewed to
because they are doesn't know a little
bit more math but I got them to think
and the average time took was about 20
minutes with the longest being 45 and
the shortest being 7 minutes to answer
all questions back to cleaning the data
but this time a deadline just visualize
it I want to start handling the model I
want to start using this stuff to see
what I can predict what can I use this
data for and that's where Python came
into in play so I just have to load in
the data and the nice thing how I set it
up was a pipe element equals whatever
I'm looking for if I want to use the
alpha wave I can use the out I just
change that variable to be beta
or anything I'm looking for so this may
my code really reusable especially as I
want to use further experiments I can
continue to use that so it's something
to always keep in mind at least for me
and so this left me with a data frame
that looked like this hi my time and for
alpha and beta and delta waves ahead for
signals and that's green ops I still
needed to reassociate that with my
answer and so I used pandas and this
line at the bottom is probably the most
important thing to me because it made my
life so easy so pandas has this function
called dot between so I was able to say
for this current line in my answer file
which has the time shown and de time
answered find everything for me in my
news data set that matches there so I
was in one line I was able to save a lot
of heading for me and that left me what
the data sets that look like this so he
basically was able to say instead of
time
show me what answer if they got it
correct or incorrect for that now it was
time to actually do some data the
science and machine learning I was
really excited so just to give you a
quick background when I first did this
Karis had just come out he was still
just getting kind of known tensorflow
was still baby version so it was that's
the kind of Huron o if you did a Google
search at the time everyone said use
fionna usb on O so I was able to
actually to use grand Taylor's vanilla
RNA which I found on github and he made
these beautiful classes that where you
can just input your parameters and you
only have to understand you'll have to
understand all of Fionna to build these
strong networks but instead you just set
in the parameters and manipulate it a
little bit as you need so originally I
wanted to use raw ft values because of
that previous research that said wavelet
is best I was like let me just see what
happens with
FFT instead so you may be confused by
the 516 in point notes well for the rasa
tea for every single signal because
there were four of them
it had 129 when it got converted into
that space so that gave me the 516 input
dose and I had an eighty hidden notes
layer with the one output layer and a
thousand epochs now this is a lot of
ethics and that was one thing we kept
monitoring is is it overtraining itself
is it overtraining and it wasn't until a
hit around 1500 so we decided you know a
thousand epochs gave us some of the best
output but you can't just throw out
neural network and say look how awesome
this is look at how well I did two other
classifiers too so I used to work oh
when I use these classifiers but you can
also use them in scikit-learn I just
personally at the time had a lot of
experience with Wicca so I did it on
nearest neighbor decision tree random
forth and sequential minimal
optimization and that was me with my rmn
fairly outperforming decision tree on
SML not the greatest results and it was
kind of where I originally stopped doing
some of my research but as all these
libraries developed and as everything
started moving forward I want to move
forward more with my research and this
is where Kara started becoming a lot
more know and it just developed so much
more and even now this recently CN TK is
available as a back-end on Keros so it's
constantly getting developed which
allows me to have my program constantly
getting better so I'm just going to show
you guys a very simple cures program to
show the flexibility of how many
experiments have to run without having
to change a lot of my data so this one
I'm just I'm going to use an LSTA so an
LLC M has the batch size and needs the
windowing that you want and then how
many items are in at that window at that
instance and you all see a little
confused of the two output nodes so I
wanted to say predict if it's correct
and predict if it's incorrect and I'll
take the hi
one I also have so I have the one layer
of LCM and just one dense layer so it
looks like this now if you see at the
dense layer let's say I want its output
only one instead I could change this to
one change this to be sigmoid and then
change this to be binary cross entropy
so doing this sometimes causes a
difference in how your out your data
outputs but in this case it's such a
simple and there really wasn't much of a
difference and I go ahead and call
evaluate and predict so I can mostly the
predictors to give me those actual Y's
on my test so I can send them from a
classification report see kind of where
I get out so with this very very very
simple LOC M I get something not that
great so this is currently where all my
research is focused I'm trying to figure
out what weight brainwaves are the best
one to use what combination is there
something I need to do differently with
the brainwaves before I pass it in so
this is currently where all my research
is I have tons of experiments list of
them that I'm trying to run through but
that's great
so so let's say I had a model right and
I currently am using my previous
broadest ft value but I want to build an
actual prototype with this now so UT
Kanter to actually build a system with
the muse headband developer it um
functions and so the actual prototype is
just this little window and it's green
as you're thinking correct and if you
start going down the wrong path and
start thinking incorrectly it turns
yellow and then turns red nothing too
sophisticated but the actual code is
really simple to build and I won't have
to do a lot of change for it so this is
the muse right three calls the
dispatcher and in here it says basically
look for this when you get a signal that
has this trigger this handler so I'll
have three of these handlers right
basically each one for those sensors
and it always goes in order zero one two
three so I know as soon as I receive
signal three I can say okay now that I
have an array of 516 element go ahead
and call my dot predict function and
that so am I guess thought and you'll
see I have my answer and from here I can
just go ahead and update my other
process which is my actual visual so the
team can third I never used before it
was actually really simple to set up and
there's a lot of documentation out there
in the web if you need to make a quick
GUI so I just go ahead and call it
peeking through and then add buttons
whatever you want right and the best
thing is I just have to continuously
check in color and if we're coming here
this TC so this is my like thought
counter and this is actually a shared
variable between my other process which
is the muse which is constantly reading
in the signal and the T and my actual
peeking through process so if you have
questions on that and how to share
values I can definitely answer them
afterwards when you're working with
locks and everything so I sign up there
I have a threshold that's still kind of
figuring out like where should I say if
they start syncing this many incorrect
times should be yellow red stuff like
that but it just goes ahead called
change color and I just say change the
frame background to whatever color I
want so pretty simple but I saw the one
step and I still a lot of development
for this so as I've mentioned earlier I
wanted to determine which values or
combination of values are the best and I
want to see what happens if I switch
over from FFT to wavelet transform by
Kurgan and Sherman ref said was the best
combination for brain waves I also just
want to gather more data for more
subjects I am about 10 or 15 subjects I
just go out because the headband ended
up moving and there was just a lot of
issues with the data and it's like
that's not really there
brain wave and also just want to forget
development type more I want to put it
not just on the computer from the phone
maybe a little vibrate instead or those
wristwatch watching or wrist watches or
other devices that you can wear on your
wrist maybe a slight little vibrate
instead so it doesn't distract the user
from the actual problem so the quick
references to Graham Taylor's R and N
and the mute developer toolkit you can
also just google them and it pops up and
then quick shout-out to dr. Joshua
across who is my advisor during this
project and continuously still helps me
thank you
all right Thank You Katie
[Applause]